frick frick don't do this not this time
no God come on where's a palette
I'm in can I close it oh my God the bro
okay ha ha Fazbear injection what
what kind of injection you talking about
what is this
please tell me that that guy cannot come
in here what am I looking at
uh it's under a tarp wait what is this
is that blood
is that spilled the blood why is there a
poster there
okay I can't go in those
let me try turning on the power
go in Fazbear get eaten by animatronic
extract brain juice put in jar put many
brain juice jars in Electro box
put brain juice jar in data make sell
Robo plus eyeball equal man
send a text to your crush this is your
sign and then eight repeat
I think
is there supposed to be like a tape to
play here
I feel like there is
oh here we go
when she came in she was nervous her
sloppy hair and clothes were very
noticeable I noticed she was an
unsociable person I was able to
appreciate a certain rejection of
external people she thinks a lot about
when what she's going to say when she
talks about her life it seems she has no
Hobbies her life while she worked with
Fazbear entertainment seemed to be less
monotonous and more social
she mentioned that she almost made it to
work as a night guard on Fazbear's
canceled Mega Pizza Plex her childhood
seems to have been bad perhaps by
traumatic events although she doesn't
want to talk about it she mentioned that
an old co-worker committed suicide with
a guillotine paper cutter
what
she doesn't remember who he was so we
shouldn't have been someone so important
to her at the end I noticed that she
left the room quickly okie dokie then
still don't know what that's all about
but I'm sure the lore is juicy
no
good I was about to say
I think I could have come in here I
would have been so mad how could you
ever get me an ear
all right
oh are you kidding me
if I die there not only do oh you are
kidding me well does that just spoil
everything then does that just spoil
everything if the door's not open
well then what the hell what what am I
gonna do when I what I'll never know
I found the key and I went in there but
there was no tape
and I don't know if there was tapes on
other desks but it was hard enough just
to get the key in the first place
why didn't the door stay open
what
oh I could just continue it Oh I thought
I had to play through
oh okay well all right well that was a
side quest that didn't pan out well for
me but it is what it is and we're all
gonna be fine I'm fine you're fine we're
all fine
ah
use the levers on the vents to light
them up with a flash
use the monitor options to defend
yourself from dangers call and repel
system complete the puzzles and get out
of the room before someone gets you or
time Runs Out
oh right of course
[Music]
of course I remember this
foreign
that I need to know about
oh that's not good wait wait slick huh
wait what do I do wait stop stop stop
oh I don't know what to do about that oh
I don't I don't know what to do about
that oh the call and repel system right
is that what I was supposed to do
you can't get me I'm Secret
every Afton punch will make the often
punch what are we talking about here
these tips don't ever make any sense
because I don't know what they're
talking about
like what in the world are you talking
about
and also God I hate this flashlight
yep here we go whatever this means
I don't know what this does
ah get back
get back I just have to hit him hard
enough
[Music]
what
oh you're blocking me eh
oh hold on
yep no [__] it's back let's get back
that's what I thought
foreign
[Music]
what was that
oh
that's a timer ah
okay timer understood
[Music]
damn it
what is that whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa
hey whoa hey whoa Wham
all right well that knocked my block off
she will be off limits keep an eye on
the woods to make sure she's not coming
if you see her activate repel system to
avoid her reaching the fence and jumping
it I don't even know I could do the
repel system what are you talking about
you freak you freak what does it Afton
punch you freak
they really don't like to tell you
anything that's going on in these
it's like Great British Bake Off and
it's just like yeah whatever figure it
out you know bake the cake make the owl
you know
oh thank you
all right
external door
oh I guess that is a concern then
of course
[Music]
wait a minute
hey wait a minute that was quick
all right okay
so you're gonna be a little bit of a
oh sassy about it keep an eye on the
motion detector in the projector room
what's the projector room
if you're in the project what are you
eat what are you referring to
what in the world are you even talking
about
foreign
[Music]
thank you
whoa what is that
call system
I called you
[Music]
oh damn it wow that was that was a waste
wow couldn't go worse couldn't have gone
worse might have gone worse but couldn't
have
[Music]
free oh wait freaks
what did you hear what I was saying what
[Music]
foreign
I don't know
damn it how do I get to that one
[Music]
foreign
I hope there's not another round after
that because I don't know what I'm doing
I don't know what I'm doing at all what
am I am I solving a puzzle here
[Music]
am I doing anything
I don't know what's going on here
[Music]
foreign
I see you there
holy [__]
oh my God if you see that his head is up
get ready
ah he will be moving very subtly well I
didn't notice that I just didn't realize
I needed to close the door first I
thought it was call system if you don't
know what to do try looking for
something you can interact with
oh thank you oh keep that in mind you
couldn't have given me a normal goddamn
flashlight
couldn't have given me a normal one
it's not even just that the mechanic of
it is Annoying It's the noise of it the
noise is just like incredibly annoying
[Music]
hello
Pizza
[Music]
oh oh
must be a powerful light
okay
[Music]
interesting
all right but I'm ready for all of it
because at the very least this is
straightforward it may not seem like it
it is very straightforward
[Music]
oh frick
no come on
whoa oh frick oh okay well uh I'm not
gonna really help is it now
it's kind of working actually if I had
maybe gone down the hallway I would have
been just fine but I thought I didn't
get it in time okay I gotta get better
about all of this stuff all this stuff
is what I'm gonna get better at I'm
ready to win
dude
[Music]
I hate this flashlight I hate this
flashlight
it's the worst thing ever made in a game
[Music]
damn it I've ride over it well I'm an
[__]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
oh God oh God close
oh God
holy [__]
God damn you
okay
go
what are you doing
[Music]
oh he's not doing the thing what do you
mean
I think I did it
okay yippee
oh really my God you guys are active
at least you waited for me to actually
start to learn what's going on oh that
didn't get you did it oh it did okay it
did you're not there your head's not up
we're all good
oh come on
this isn't even the fourth round
[Music]
there we go God damn I don't like this
game I see you over there
go away
what
what the hell was that
all right whatever
oh crap
oh my God can that stop
horrible
[Music]
foreign
man that's much easier wow I was just
bad at this game holy [__] I didn't even
hear you I just saw you
turns out I'm terrible at this game
because it's so much easier than it
seems
[Music]
wow
I'm dumb
holy [__]
oh that's not good
that's not good
okay what did I do I get my prize in the
projector room I ain't going in there
until he's done
three
oh
foreign
yep that is
okay
projector room what do you mean
projector room
foreign
what what is what what's the projector
room
okay so uh two is okay that's good so
then this should just be I should just
cycle through until it's right
[__] what happened
key okay key unlock one of these
perfect got it projector
huh
hi what's up hello how are you
um what's going on
have a jolly good time with Lolly
lollies
what do I do
where's my prize
oh I see
oh frick oh come on oh come on
I should have just left that on while I
was in there and I'm back at the
beginning
I don't understand because you're not
telling me anything I don't know what
the prize is
[Music]
bam done
Okay so we've got nope it's not there
I live into three good
oh I hear you
what the frick was that well that's not
good
[Music]
[Applause]
hold on
elephants is three
I'm gonna need two I need to have two
before I can do anything I might be in
there
oh one bunny
there we go why have you not done your
thing yet was I wrong about this
there Frick finally
you get repelled I can open this okay so
I think I'm looking for pieces of paper
oh God that just pushed you away
because you're an [__] now that I
have a second to breathe
[Music]
so he's looking at it and he says no so
I need to find
apparently
the pieces oh one two two oh
[Applause]
well I don't have a coin do I
[Music]
oh good thing I came back
so where could I find a coin
where would I find a coin in here
said Bryce it said prize there's no
prize in here oh prize okay got it
one perfect
that's handy that let me just take a
look real quick
[Music]
okay
put this here Lolly lollies oh boy
well this is taking a while okay
holy [__]
okay
I'm gonna go check
oh you're kidding me God why didn't I
leave I thought I left it on I thought I
left the repel system on
foreign
all right I know what to do I know what
to do
okay I'll get that a second I didn't
leave the rebelsism on
no one's here
how are you doing you're heading out up
good
[Music]
look at that
okay give me this
this good
this down there good
this up here good God okay we're gonna
step away stepping away
[Music]
[Applause]
came just in time for you son of a [__]
[Music]
oh wait a minute that's not good holy
[__]
I swear to God his head was up I just
must be catching it pretty early these
times because I'm so goddamn good at
this game
there we go
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
there no not that
no not that one
what do you do what was that
[Music]
[Applause]
was that not good enough
foreign
[Music]
oh my God what do I do with this I don't
know what I do with this what the frick
do I do with this what do I do with this
what
do I do what
give me your nose what do I do with this
oh the chains right of course
foreign
[Applause]
wish I could run hope I don't need to
run
oh I hope I don't read I can't run at
all if I die because I'm out of stamina
right here in this moment I'm gonna be
so mad
yeah I never come back from out of
breath ever why would I do that
just go through it
don't open it go through it using my
freaking wall walking
oh
I'm still out of breath
[Music]
oh
what is
uh sorry oh
[Music]
human motion detected
yep
oh
[Music]
I finally got him a body I had to find
his original body to extract his Remnant
and I reactivated to create this new
body I used parts of his human body and
an endoskeleton from the attraction it
doesn't sound stable but it works so
I'll use it while building his new body
I experimented with the remnant in order
to better understand his behavior
my final conclusion about it is if the
remnant is injected into a body with a
soul the conscience of the person to
whom the remnant belonged will be
trapped inside the mind of the soul and
due to something I don't understand yet
the conscience of the
[Music]
the conscience of the ejected Remnant is
transformed into energy that the soul
uses to bond more with the body that is
to say the remnant makes a person live
longer causing a side effect the
conscience of the injected Remnant is
trapped in the mind until the person
dies the conscious consciences should
not be a problem for William's mind it
has been a through a lot becoming
stronger with each day of his life I
don't know what any of that meant
I don't know what any of that meant oh
wow
oh wow
hey wow hey wow corpse blueprint for a
corpse
all right
well this is lovely